ON TELEVISION WELL IS NOTHING
SHE LOVES MORE THAN
INSURRECTION.
NICOLE WALLACE IS IDENTIFYING
A NEW INSURRECTION SAYING "LET'S
GO BRANDON."
THIS WAS HER REACTION TO AN
OREGON MHO UTTERED THE
PHRASE ON A CHRISTMAS EVE CALL
WITH JOE BIDEN.
>> LET ME TELL YOU WHY THIS
MATTERS
MATTERS.
THE ASYMMETRY OF SAYING F-YOU TO
A SITTING PRESIDENT IN A CALL IN
FRONT OF YOUR 4 KIDS, DON'T LOOK
PAST THIS.
THIS IS NOT A STORY ABOUT GIVING
AIR TIME TO A MAGA GUY IT.
THIS IS THE INSURRECTION IN FULL
COLOR.
>> Will: VICTOR DAVIS HANSON
JOINS US LIVE.
I SEE YOUR SMILE.
I SPOKE TO YOU A WEEK AGO.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE VERBAL TICKS
THAT TAKE OVER THE HUMAN MIND
WANT THE MIND OF THE LE.
NOW INSURRECTION IS THE MOST
FREQUENT AND RECENT MENTAL TICK.
>> YES.
IF SAYING "LET'S GO BRANDON" IS
INSURRECTION, WHAT WOULD BE
A CNN CONTRIBUTOR HOLDING UP
DONALD'S DECAPITATED HEAD?
WHAT WAS NIGHT AFTER NIGHT IN
CENTRAL PARKAVING A LOOK ALIKE
DONALD TRUMP AS CAESAR BEING
STABBED TO DEATH AND HILLARY
CLINTON SAID THE PRESIDENT WAS
NOT LEGITIMATE AND URGED JOE
BIDEN NOT TO CONCEDE UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCE?
WHAT WAS THE OBAMA PENTAGON
LAWYER WRITING WE SHOULD
CONSIDER REMOVING TRUMP BY THE
25TH AMENDMENT, IMPEACHMENT OR
A MILITARY COUP?
A MILITARY COUP WAS ON THE MINDS
OF A LOT OF RETIRED GENERALS.
TWO WROTE LETTERS AND OTHER SAID
THAT TRUMP SHOULD LEAVE THE
SOONER THE BETTER.
WE KNOW WHAT IT'S REALLY ABOUT.
DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN BEATEN TO
DEATH.
SO HAS JANUARY 6TH.
TH ARE AFRAID OF DEMOCRACYND
AFRAID THE PEOE WILL SPEAK.
A MONTH AGO WE WOULD TALK ABOUT
THE THEME DEMOCRACY IS BROKEN IN
2022 AND THERE WILL BE A COUP IN
2024.
NOW WE HAVE THE INSURRECTION.
IT'S ALL A FEAR ABOUT THE
MID-TERMS.
IF THEY WERE RATIONAL THEY WOULD
SAY THIS AGENDA IS NOT GOOD FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE NEED TO REBOOT.
THEY CAN'T BECAUSE THEY ARE
HARD-CORE.
>> Will: YOU SAID SOMETHING ELSE
FASCINATING.
THIS IS A REPLACEMENT FOR HAVING
A POSITIVE AGENDA OF DOING
SOMETHING TO HELP SOLVE THE
NATION'S PROBLEMS.
VILIFYING YOUR POLITICAL
OPPONENT AS INSURRECTIONISTS OR
RACISTS IS THE LAST POLITICAL
TOOL OF A FAILING REGIME.
TELL ME ABOUT THAT.
10 YEARS AGO THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION PRIDED ITSELF ON
HAVING AN AGENDA FOR AMERICA.
NOW IT'S ABOUT TRANSFORMING YOUR
POLITICAL OPPONENT INTO THE
DEVIL.
>> IT WAS.
EVEN BARACK OBAMA REALIZED WHEN
HIS AGENDA STARTED TO FAIL.
HE JUST DISAPPEARED AND ALLOWED
THE DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS TO
FIGHT FOR THE NEXT
ADMINISTRATION ON HIS LAST YEAR.
RTYDISAPPEARED